AUTHOR OF "AN INTRODUCTION TO
THE MUELLER REPORT," HARVARD LAW
PROFESSOR ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
I WILL START WITH YOU.
I READ YOUR CALM, ALMOST READ
THE WHOLE THING ON RADIO.
YOU HAVE TRIED UP UNTIL TODAY,
AND WE HAD MUCH DISAGREEMENT, TO
DEFEND MUELLER.
TO RESPECT THE PROCESS.
EVEN THOUGH WE ALL KNOW THAT AN
ARTICLE TWO, THE PRESIDENT
ALWAYS HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
FIRE HIM FOR CONFLICTS.
HE JUST WOULD HAVE BEEN
REPLACED.RCE
VERY FEW PEOPLE SEEM TO POINT
THAT OUT.
WHAT DID YOU SEE THE DAY THAT
CHANGED HER MIND?
>> WHAT I THOUGHT TODAY WAS HIM
PUTTING HIS THUMB, HIS ELBOW ON
THE SCALE WHEN HE SAID, "IF WE
HAD HAD CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT CLEARLY DID NOT COMMIT
A CRIME, WE WOULD HAVE SAID SO."
THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY
INAPPROPRIATE FOR HIM TO SAY.
IT WAS WORSE THAN ANYTHING THAT
COMEY SAID WHEN HE EXONERATED
HILLARY CLINTON AND THEN SAID,
BUT SHE ENGAGED IN AN EXTREMELY
CARELESS CONDUCT.
EVERYBODY CONDEMNED THAT.
THIS IS MUCH, MUCH WORSE.
IT DOESN'T SHOW THAT HE HAD A
MOTIVE TO HELP THE DEMOCRATS
HERE.
THERE IS NO OTHER POSSIBLE
MOTIVE WHY HE WOULD HAVE GONE
OUT OF HIS WAY TO SAY THAT BRADY
COULD T HAVE EASILY SAID THE
OPPOSITE.
IF WE HAD CONFIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT DIDN'T COMMIT A CRIME,
WE WOULD HAVE SAID IT.
IF WE HAD CONFIDENCE THAT HE I
COMMITTED A CRIME, WE WOULD HAVE
SAID IT.
BUT NO, HE EMPHASIZED ON THE
POSSIBILITY THE PRESIDENT MIGHT
HAVE COMMITTED A CRIME.
THAT WENT WELL BEYOND HIS
AUTHORITY AS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT ALSO SHOWED WE NEVER SHOULD
HAVE HAD A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
WE SHOULD HAVE HAD AN OBJECTIVE,
NEUTRAL, NONPARTISAN
INVESTIGATIVE COMMISSION LOOKING
INTO THE ENTIRE EFFORT OF
RUSSIA, TO INTRUDE ITSELF INTO
THE PARK SHOULD BE 16 ELECTION
AND CONTINUING TO THE '20
ELECTION,
AND PROPOSING EFFORTS TO